alors bonjour à la planète tout le monde
vous entend bonjour sa fait et là vous
avez de l'énergie qu'ils avaient mangé
votre sandwich ce matin c'est tous en
forme wii gêné saveur d'une ligue 1 qui
a pas pris de vacances est pourtant un
petit peu j'en avais pris trop de la cdu
alors autant à table en chêne du côté de
la technique web notre webmestre cette
semaine marie jobin qui est du secteur
français de radio canada international
paloma martinez qui joue surtout des
patinoires ici à bercy
une collègue de travail estimée et alice
chantal jean d'esme qui est notre
collègue depuis plusieurs années je
pense que j'ai vu des articles de vous
qui dopera mandat 2013
oh oui c'est vrai c'était sûr à la radio
six premières
aujourd'hui vous connaissez le règlement
il ya un jeu un jeu vous gagnez des
points et un grand prix de participation
à la fin d'émission
celui de mon estime et ensuite pendant
cette émission il ya un invité mystère
qui s'y glisse et pour devenir l'antenne
l'émission vous savez comment ça
commence il ya seulement cinq images
d'habitude très bien et puis on va
regarder tous ensemble cette vidéo est
ce que est ce que vous pouvez allumer
l'écran numéro 38 que je puisse voir si
on voit les vidéos c'est pas possible
parce que nos internautes peuvent voir
la vidéo mais nous pas donner quelques
mines de deviner c'est quoi si j'ai
écouté avant de devenir le sujet parce
qu'il n'est pas prêt tout à fait là il
va faire un gros sujet les bélugas cette
semaine vous y travaillez chantal au 8
août a fait avec un article très très
drôle si c'est un jeune homme de 16 ans
qui a chassé tout un tout un béluga tout
une baleine à tout juste 16 ans et qui a
enflammé la toile avec son histoire
et puis moi je travaille en espagne
cette semaine
et puis c'est drôle parce qu'on sait
qu'on en discute et juste avant
une campagne du même sujet mais deux
endroits différents
moi aussi je parle d'une chasse à la
baleine mais dans le nord du canada
tu le suis loin ses alouettes mais je ne
connais pas le nom en français le cdh
malin en particulier mais on l'appelle
la baleine boréale ou beau et doux et en
anglais et puis cela fait plusieurs
années que cette communauté des cadeaux
et d'efforts chic pour mr bean
n'arrivait pas à pouvoir chasser la
baleine parce que malgré l'autorisation
du gouvernement
ils sont pas toujours très bien pour
exception mais il a fait ce qu'est la
baleine s'approche pas assez ou c'est
trop difficile de la chasse et dont mais
cette fois ci c'était vraiment content
parce qu'ils sont réussi à chasser ces
grosses baleines qui va alimenter aussi
plus cher quand même une merde dans la
benne le produit de la chasse il faut
comme le redistribue au sein de la
communauté
pour avoir ça n'est pas de divorcer de
la baleine exactement donc ça peut durer
à plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
parfois dépendamment des communautés et
puis c'est une grande fierté pour les
peuples du nord du canada
vu donc que le peuple inuit donc j'ai
entendu vous savez la cilicie news en
anglais le service anglais de
radio-canada à une aussi une équipe à
ninon quitter tout qu'est la langue de
notre carla et puis j'ai vu là là
la reporter raconter la chasse parce
qu'il est allé interviewer les chasseurs
des chansons qui avaient presque
certains c'était magnifique
il y avait son temps oui exactement à 4
était une de l'énergie pour aller
chasser la baleine je pense que lui
donnait à mener sa sagesse
on a fait une émission sur les baleines
l été dernier
et puis où se retrouver sans les uns
chez des émissions toutes les émissions
vous cliquez sur l'onglet sur la page
première d'accueil de radio canada
international y trouver ça je pense est
au mois de juillet de l'an dernier
aujourd'hui nouvelle émission nouveau
thème c'est pas celui des baleines
on est prêt à plonger d'accord vidéo
cinq images on y va et puis dès que vous
sentez que vous avez vous êtes sur la
piste du sujet vous un vous n'hésitez
pas vous pouvez y aller avant votre
collègue alors tout le monde autour de
la planète jauge du csaig image et ça y
est ça commence avec sow que ce que
c'est une grosse structure
ça ressemble à la ronde un jeune foire
du jeu ouais les nouvelles roues un
moment c'est pas le nouvel endroit où on
est potes pierre ont des montgolfières
oui il y en a beaucoup
tu sets quadrillés l'image 5ème images
ça serait c'est jean sur richelieu
serait saint jean sur le richelieu mais
encore quel est le thème de l'émission
aujourd'hui
pour garder l'international de
montgolfières de saint jean sur
richelieu
mais on était prédite y est presque
bienvenue aux amis par là mais on va
amener nos auditeurs pour leur montrer
où ça se trouve c'est près de montréal
saint jean sur richelieu voile sur la
carte petit point rouge
oui on va agrandir la carte voilà où ça
se trouve un peu près moi je dirais 35
minutes 15 minutes de route de mots rien
non loin de la frontière américaine où
aller voir en pointillés au bas de la
carte
ça ça voilà ça c'est les états unis
c'est là où se trouve l'oncle 30
précisément dans le sud est
c'est dans le sud quelque chose riquet
c'est sa gauche écoutez on va montrer
des images de l'international de
montgolfières de saint jean sur
richelieu père sinnott thème aujourd'hui
on a des belles images à vous montrer
filmé par une équipe de radio canada
vidéo numéro deux et pendant qu'on
regarde ça en singe vous donne un bref
historique j'avais une idée de combien
ça fait combien d'années qu'on qu'on a
ce genre d'événements internationaux
25-25 tout proche tout prêts tout près
oui oui vous laisser rouler les images
pour qu'on les voit ce sont des images
qui roule
il suffit de laisser aller pour quel
rôle c'est amusant
voici des gens qui sait des aérostiers
jeu moi je fais pas ça va mais je pense
que ce sera le terme et 1984 la première
édition c'est le plus grand festival au
canada il y en a un plus grand dans la
francophonie c'est en france est le plus
grand au monde
on va aller faire un tour un peu plus
tard à cet endroit mais pour le moment
ça se passe chez nous ça dépend des
années cinq cents à 125 150 équipes qui
se relaient pour monter dans le ciel
ils sont un événement familial parce que
c'est pas juste des gros ballons qu'ils
mentent
êtes vous déjà monté sur le ballon comme
ça je pense qu'on me retrouverais régime
moi d'ailleurs je voulais vous vous
posez la question à ce moment qu'ils
répondent aux questions à ces missions
c'est vous est ce que vous seriez comme
ça dans une nacelle s'est nouée en
caisse les ans ça pour être les autres
tout à fait oui pouvoir garder la terre
autrement j'ai pas moi j'ai ma licence
de pilote d'avion j pléthore laner dont
je sais pas si c'est parce que là c'est
ballot éclater la dimension ludique
oui professionnels non mais moi j'aime
bien voir les ailes
alors si le moteur l'âge on fait
toujours planer s'appela non mais tu
magescas dessin train qui main sur les
fils électriques
j'ai même essayé dit fonce à l'aéroport
de saint-hubert modérée au port de saint
jean puis il ya des champs partout
autour alors si il ya un problème avec
la météo ils peuvent atterrir sans se
faire de mal non ça ces images tournées
au matin 1
c'est plutôt rassurant d'atterrir sans
se faire du oui parce que si je passe on
peut dire à tes rires je pense qu'on
peut dire à boeing a beau nous prend pas
pour des plus beaux mots plus beaumont
plus politique que c'est beau c'est
quand même assez récent nous on nous on
est jeune oui alors nous on est en année
avec ça mais ceux qui sont plus vieux là
qui ont qui en dix ans 60 ans rue
connaissent pas soit vraiment c'est à la
fin des années 50
qu'ils ont utilisés ils ont découvert
les fibres synthétiques qui permettait
donc de mettre du propane
c'était plus résistants donc on peut
aller plus haut plus loin plus en plus
sécuritaire et c'est devenu vraiment
populaire donc c'est à partir de ce
moment là que c'est ça de mon prénom
savoir ces groupes allant dans l'est
dans le ciel et des collections de gros
ballons
est ce que vous savez pourquoi ça vole
histoire scientifique parce que je le
sais archimède qui est à l'auteur de
tout ça c'est connu c'est un truc qui
déplace les quelque chose ça déplace
autre chose je pense
prince se déplace de l'air s'est pas
beaucoup d'air chaud yg on fait ça avec
de l'air chaud ou du propane votre avec
du pape a mis un peu plus qu'une vue sur
les particules prennent de l'expansion
sa mansarde le reste de l'air autour
et puis dans je pense qu'on est pas
manquer ça se dirige dans les airs tout
seul il ya quelque chose dans la nasa
spitzer le ballon qu'on dirige non il ya
quelqu'un qui tire avec les ficelles
depuis le sol comme ça non
côté partie de celles je pense qu'on
aurait besoin d'un spécialiste pour
mieux nous expliquer et sa faune si
cette personne s'en vient rassurez vous
pour le moment c'est la première manche
notre jeu de la grosse boule du savoir
on revient en studio on lâche nos boules
et ça vaut 20 points sans grosse boule
jouée au quai s'inquiète un studio est
aussi grosse à tous ceux qui jouent avec
nous chaque semaine le sable était
toujours là cette boule c'est pas c'est
pas parce qu'elle est on parle dénonçant
la non violence sur cette semaine donc
20 points pour ce preuve cette première
manche y en a trois missions
voici le préambule de la question
référendaire il est généralement admis
que la montgolfière est inventeur
montgolfier je pense joseph michel et
jacques etienne était sur xvème siècle
16 ème siècle 17e au 18e siècle
dix sept tient dix septième ciel c'est
bien donc on a mis la table à l'iss vous
voulez ajouter que quel bolide se
déplacer l'assiette ou qu'est ce que
vous faites avec ça j'avoue que c'est
une histoire que j'ai eu à lire dans un
petit livre avec mon fiston
mais j'arrive pas à me situer par
rapport à la crise annie si je me joins
m aventurer dans le xviiie siècle est le
siècle des lumières
non c'est bien et qu'il est et reste le
plus rappelé alors approché le siècle
puis rapprocher c'était le 18 h
18e 18e pas j'irai avec la proposition
partie du xviiie siècle qu'on a fait ou
bi sortes de découvertes scientifiques
et techniques
tu me dis que ça a peut-être servi à
quelque chose c'est avait eu l'intuition
et vous êtes des lumières 20 points
chacun sait pas autour de 1800 non 1783
un petit peu avant qu'on ait coupé la
tête à 6800 on est rendu au dix neuvième
siècle c'est sa main d'accord mais quand
même ça s'est passé un 19 septembre
pourquoi peut-être la confusion 19,7
on est monté à 4 180 mètres de hauteur
sans en piste et c'est hallucinant
combien de fric
sept lots par 3.3 dans et autour de 1200
1300 avait fait des études en
mathématiques évident dont je parlais
tantôt avec un personnage central
charles mobbs avec son ballon dirigeable
il se rendait en amérique du sud avec sa
copine je sais plus et elisabeth quelque
chose comme ça mon fils me dira mais je
crois que c'était au xviiie siècle
locale écoutez cette semaine c'est la
première fois que ça nous arrive je
pense en un an et demi pas d'entrevue
skype
il ya une entrevue une interview et
mystère mais pas d'entrevue ce cas
puisque ce festival international est un
petit peu
non nous a promis une invitée elle s'est
désistée à la dernière minute et savez
comment c'est les tout le monde était
parti en l'air c'est très sérieux c'est
très sérieux
j avec une personne pour accorder des
entrevues et malheureusement elle est
partie alors voilà quand elle
redescendra elle se reprend avant une
prochaine fois exactement ça c'est à une
heure et demie j'ai appris ça donc mais
nous on sait on est très professionnel
on s'est dit on a évidemment des
spécialistes que nous avons déjà
intervenu à 1,6 par rapport à ce
festival international puisque après
tout il ya radio canada international et
il ya le festival de montgolfières
international de saint jean sur le
richelieu communauté d'esprit ici alors
voici nous avons parlé avec madame
marie-claude beauvais ce qu'on veut
entendre dans quelques instants qui est
la vice-présidente marketing de
l'international des montgolfières de
saint jean sur le richelieu dans une
toute récente édition et elle nous parle
de non seulement des montgolfières mais
des visiteurs des simples spectateurs
plus de 350000 attendu qu'en ce moment
même
et voici dans cette entrevue réalisée
par di dio ti et pendant qu'on les
écoute on vous présente donc d'image
pour nous inspirer d'autres images
poétiques de ce festival des
montgolfières notre vidéo numéro 3
partout à travers le monde dont nous
avons des pilotes de montgolfières dans
quelques pilotes possède sa propre bombe
à la fia nous l'accueillons les pilotes
proviennent autant vu des états unis du
brill de l'europe de l'australie dont
vraiment que parce que à travers le
monde et permet désormais vaincu mon
gazière nous avons également des formes
spéciales dont ce sont des éléments
gaulle vient qui représenterait d'image
d'unir à un hippocampe dans un claude
etc
ces personnes dont qui a peur que la
montgolfière est ce qu'elles payent ces
personnes là pour participer au festival
ou bien la participation est plutôt
encouragé gratuite
évidemment nous voulons bien accueillir
et qu'il est là qui proviennent d'un peu
partout à travers le monde donc et nous
nous faisons évidemment aux devoirs
de les accueillir de lino rire
évidemment de payer pour les nuitées
donc de vraiment les soutes et pour
qu'ils aient envie de revenir
année après année c'est une activité
familiale donc le public visite c'est la
famille c'est vraiment la famille donc
nous avons des activités vraiment pour
les tout petits mais également pour les
adolescents et évidemment pour les
adultes donc nous ouvrons 2010 à 23h30
et dont les activités sont en continu
tout au long de la journée et les
envolées dans monrovia prennent part
pour réel à 18h le soir et certains
soirs nous avons ce que nous appelons
des nuits magiques donc les
montgolfières gonfle reste au sol et
s'illumine tels des lanternes chinoises
dont un magnifique spectacle en soirée
parce qu'évidemment le feu des brûlures
permettent aux montgolfières de déployer
leur belle couleur et donc c'est très
très très festif au sens de viser que
très rythmé c'est quand même des bêtises
explication qui viennent de marie-claude
bové vice président marketing de
l'international des montgolfières de
saint jean sur le richelieu talk
interview dans une récente édition par
notre collègue didier hoti on est prêtes
pour notre deuxième manche je vous dise
et 30 points et c'est si facile
c'est jamais facile
j'ai l'habitude des questions
compliquées c'est facile d'accord à
voici je d'agro ce bull 2e manche 30
points le record du monde décollage en
ligne donc votez collage de pas comme
des avions mais des conneries tout en
gros au décollage en ligne c'est le
langage des spécialistes des collages de
décalage de coin de couloir et
montgolfière vous êtes vraiment des
journalistes des esprits aux
journalistes
alors c'est donc ça tu es réalisé le
record du monde de nouveaux records en
j'en avais eu 1 précédemment en 2013
vrai ou faux c'est en france qu'a eu
lieu ce record du monde
la france et bien d'autres pays
j'imagine assez populaire dans beaucoup
de pays on comprendra mieux que les
ballons que ça fait le tour du monde en
80 jours
samedi que la france avait le festival
des montgolfières le plus grande
allemande donc je dirais vous allez dire
vrai oui pour 30 points vous êtes dire
vrai oui est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
veut dire faux moi oui j'ai dit fofolle
et vous maryse vous dites j'ai dit est
ce que je pourrais prendre directement
il faut choisir et moi je m'exerce faut
comme indice faux halal a c'est vrai on
n'a pas d'autres éléments pour vous
permettre 50 % de succès 5 1 % de
chances de succès 20.30 points 20 points
c'est fait c'est comme joker 10 heures
vous avez tous participé à la finale de
l'est
alors autant dire encore toute sa magie
j'aime ça quand je parle d'un sujet
j'aime toujours aller un peu plus loin
voire bon par curiosité personnelle pas
professionnel je vous assure ça va
jusqu'à quelle hauteur on peut monter
comme ça en ballon vous avez jusqu'à
temps qu'on manque pas d'exiger pour
espérer parce que là on n'aurait rien à
brûler j'imagine non plus il ya des gens
qui mentent avec des masques oui mais là
le problème c'est qu'avec le gaz on
brûle l'air mon réchaud flers calment si
la pudeur mais c'est parce qu en
altitude le gaz reprendre plus
d'expérience ion parce que moins de
molécules autour du ballon pour faire de
la compression
oui sauf qu est-ce qu on utilise le
maintien ça c'est là qu'un corps jusqu'à
200 m 400 m et 400 m beaucoup beaucoup
plus simple pour avoir un tel personnage
à la table de reportages de ballon qui
était vraiment très très très long je
vais vous proposer de regarder la vidéo
numéro cas tout le monde ensemble vous à
peu près à quelle altitude on se trouve
en dessous de la vidéo
le flash fasse attention mal à livrer
des secrets comme ça si facilement 4000
kwh à 4000 mais on est peu présente
1615 avait mis pied c'est ça même -5
3.3.3 ça se passe en france les
champions mondiaux de des montgolfières
avec des records tout ça il ne porte pas
de masque et c'est au dessus
ddd alto alors pourrait faire sa société
parce que sinon il avait froid mais j'ai
entendu quatre cents c'est pour cette
raison que j'ai là c'est pas leur corse
à 4002 quelque chose
non non c'est pas le record alors ils
n'ont pas ce qu avait un ballon spécial
indiqué c'est allé beaucoup plus haut
c'est ça il y en a une couple en fait j
ai appelé je pense c'est moi j'essaie de
me souvenir moment garner quelque chose
mon goût original ça fait le tour du
monde cette histoire c'est un 2013
et puis il avait été obligé de mettre un
masque
ouais puis il était monté avec une le
ballon l'avait propulsé presque dans la
stratosphère macarons que ça a été très
médiatisé mais regardez la numéro 5 ça
s'est passé deux ans plus tard et c'est
le c'est vraiment le record du monde en
ballon
c'est un autre américain l'histoire n'a
pas été couverts par les médias
pratiquement à l'américaine et en 1957
garantir les images d'une vidéo
présentée pire ans ted
voyez le cosmonaute basque à cette
attitude là il est il va montrer à 44
1041 1419 m il s'énerve qu'il va il va
prendre deux heures un peu plus de deux
heures à monter comme ça tiré par ne par
le ballon le voile qui décolle et savent
donc de un peu deux heures à monter il
dit que c'est extrêmement paisible et
les gens de la conférence mais vous êtes
le ballon est complètement fermé alors
c'est pas la même technologie
donc qu'est les ballons ordinaire alors
le voilà que cet homme c'est un champion
c'est un ancien directeur ingénieur en
informatique vice président de google
ancien vice président
argent et puis pour faire ça
alors oui quand tu la montée ça va bon
j'ai accéléré images parce qu'on a quand
même que une demi heure d'émission
regardez le fait pas par non non la
montgolfière oui ça non je soupçonne
qu'un parachute où il doit avoir bien à
parachute regarder comment l'ère open à
l'air tout petit
oui c'était là il atteindre la
stratosphère surnom de voile à son
équipe comme à la nasa qui le suit de
près et on va lui donner le signal
bientôt ça y est tu as atteint le record
c'est à city en a fait assez d'essence
tu va redescendre le voilà qui s'apprête
à descendre il va être il va précipiter
vers le sol
oui il va se détacher ce qui va non
santé alors le voilà il serait prêt à
prendre sa décision fatidique
j'espère qu'ils en parachute il a une
fusée c'est là déjà atterri en parachute
samarie j'ai vu ça aujourd'hui je peux
pas me présenter savait pas partie du
jeu directement
[Rires]
ils y prennent c'est comme un astronaute
dans l'espace
tout à fait il n'y a pas grand
différence est ce qu'ils sont ou pas ça
prend du temps
non huit cent mille par heure un point
si ça vous donne le kilométrage d'accord
mais en mètre par seconde
357 m je ne sais pas je pense que c'est
à une autre regard déloyale aux fêtes
autour de quoi 4,7 mais pis aller comme
ça vous êtes une pilote d'avion
anne hommel a eu aucun parachute un déjà
non oui avec les vite ça s'est super
bien passé avec les vieux c'est un
exploit souligné tu parlais il ya pas de
vous nous parler un peu plus tôt de
cette oeuvre
je suis des collègues vous nous parlez
donc de cette personne oui mais c'est un
personnage imaginaire dans un livre pour
enfants mais c'est pas de vue non celui
qui a sauté à sans parachute de
montgolfières en 2015 2015
non non rien avait une espèce de nom
c'est quelque chose dont j'ai oublié
aucun cas ce qui se passe avec 18
millions de vues sur youtube vous irez
voir ça 18 millions chercher antilles
soit un parachute fou vous allez trouver
il est je vous dit écoutez il a sauté
avec deux autres gars qui avait déposée
par hachette et ils l'ont ils ont été le
récupérer il rattraper oui bah c'est un
club qui fait des actes fous comme ça et
plus de vue qu ils ont en plus d'argent
ils font ce ca et un quatuor aux yeux
devant suivre avec des avions et là les
gens qui sont des les avions l'avion va
se rapprocher de la personne qui est en
chute libre pour la ramasser c'est
particulier non moi j'ai des regards des
laisses images
je démens j'ai déjà mal au coeur ça
donne le vertige évaluée maintenant
regarder cet hymne reportage de radio
canada
c'est il ya trois ans la même année où
il a le fouet sauter en parachute
c'est un jeune homme qui s'est envolé
sur 10 clos mais tirée par une gerbe de
ballons remplis d'hélium haye
je pense qu'il ya 23 ans quelque chose
comme ça et puis je pense qu'il est
étonné sa future du ciné et à combien de
ballons ils étaient des liens comme ça
je sens quelque part c'est une centaine
oui on peut le lire
oui 110 bah moi je vois c'est beaucoup
plus c'est toujours bien de pouvoir lire
nos anciens reporter c'est pour ça qu'on
a une chronique sur la page de 30 ans
qui s'appelle fouillé dans mon enfance
vous saviez vous êtes prêts pour la
dernière question notre jeu de cellex c
est en ce moment
30 20 alors c'est très difficile comme
question mais trop tard en général qui
gagne à ce jeu troisièmement 50 points
pression barométrique principe
d'archimède et propriétés des gaz à
différentes températures
voilà qui détermine le volume d'air
qu'il faut souffler dans une
montgolfière pour qu'elle s'élance vers
le ciel
dans le cas d'un jeune homme à calgary
safran 110 balance on le sait on a le
calcul voici la question un ballon pèse
à peu près 36 grammes par mètre cube
quel volume d'air faut-il souffler dans
le ballon le véritable ballon la
montgolfière pour remporter une seule
personne on a les obtiens j'imagine oui
50 mètres cubes pop 150 mètres cube ou
250 mètres cubes mais là ce qu'on parle
du volume une fois que l'arrêt dans le
ballon ou ce qu'on utilise ont décollé
du sol
donc là c'est pas et c'est quoi les
capitaux encore 50 dette recule 150
mètres cubes 250 mètres cubes pour une
personne de corpulence ordinaire d'y
aller si vous moi je prendrais le juste
milieu
c'est quand tout ça ça me semblerait
être un choix prudent mais je sais pas -
scientifiquement je me dirais 50 parce
que lorsque ça prend du volume ouais ça
va habiter le ballon d'accord ah la la
trois réponses fermes en aura qu'un
gagnant j'imagine d'accord oui alors qui
a répondu 250 mètres cubes mois à
l'hôpital sommes à 80 points ça varie de
250 mètres cubes dans des conditions
météorologiques très favorables comme
seule au canada à plus de vingt quatre
mille mètres cubes pour les plus grands
de montgolfières qui peuvent emporter 45
personnes pour une banque d'affaires de
45 personnes
mais là pour une seule personne en
question moi j'ai élargi réponse pour
donner plus d'information possible après
tout c'est mon travail
une seule personne si vous voyez vous en
tirez avec 250 peut-être c'est pas fini
on peux continuer encore quelques
minutes sylvain ouais d'accord on va lui
donner reportage qu'on a fait cette
semaine j'ai pas tout prix on va
regarder ce qui s'annonce on passa noms
se trouvant la colombie-britannique qui
brûlent les canadiens de l'ouest
suffoque une nouvelle réalité qui est
l'auteur de cet article 6 mois
c'est sérieux c'est tout à fait sérieux
et ce qui est intéressant c'est la
deuxième année
eux aussi important et pourquoi
réchauffement climatique mais on est
pris avec des arbres qui en 30 ans 53
cents ans
ils sont un petit vivre dans des
conditions plus froides et qu'il a à
cause des éclairs à cause des phénomènes
météorologiques les éclairs mettre le
feu et là ça brûle et on a vu des images
saisissantes de la capitale albertaine
delà de calgary aussi à me donner
calgary 5 au britannique mais tout juste
à côté à l'alberta est tout juste à côté
la sq à tshwane le manitoba et là
c'était pas fumer voyage d'ouest en est
comme les grands courants et c'est ce
qui arrive d'accord je voulais justement
de cette semaine elle travaille pas en
français mais en langue espagnole un
couvert aussi les feux dé forêt en
colombie-britannique parce que il y a
des des brigades des pompiers qui
viennent de partout dans le monde dont
le mexique il ya du mexique il ya autour
de 380 pompiers qui sont venus en forme
exactement mais il y a des états unis
pili a d'ailleurs aussi donc c'est
vraiment un cran c'est intéressant qui
viennent du mexique parce que quand on y
pense
les feux montent la côte ouest donc
mexique etats unis et canada sont
connectés pour parce qu'ils sont
d'habitude ont l'expertisé et à man on
va aller dans un autre partage cette
semaine celui effectué par la fait plus
qu'une mais là c'est la question de
alice les élections générales
la province c'est officiel c'est
qu'annoncé disons
la campagne électorale va démarrer
bientôt dans quelques semaines je crois
c'est le 23 23 les élections c'est le
premier est donc le premier temps qu'on
accorde tout à fait et donc il ya cette
possibilité qui est offerte aux
personnes à l'extérieur de la province
de pouvoir voter par anticipation et par
la poste et donc j'ai trouvé que c'était
important d'en parler que les personnes
soient au courant qu'elles soient
sensibilisés alors si on est prisonnier
de la ville de toronto
on peut par exemple se trouve à toronto
son papa prison on se trouve à toronto
où ailleurs au canada
si on est parti en voyage quelque part
on est pas privé de son droit de vote on
peut le faire en allant s'inscrit sur le
site internet corps et puis on va
recevoir tous les documents nécessaires
pour pouvoir le faire et je suis au
courant que c'est une c'est une pratique
courante pour les pour la france les
extraits de textes expatriés néologisme
trouve que ça veut dire mais pour les
québécois je savais pas que c'était
passé est ce que ces nouveaux comme
c'est pas nouveau que c'est pas nouveau
j'en ai discuté avec une représentante
d'élections québec qui m'a dit c'est une
expérience qu'on veut renouveler parce
que ça a apporté de bons résultats donc
c'est pas du tout nouveau et les
québécois le savent ils sont habitués à
la fantastique
oui j'avais quelque chose à ajouter et
je ne travaille pas avec vous mais
j'étais chaud s'ajoutaient parce que je
vous cette année il ya eu des élections
au mexique et puis on a eu les les votes
pas part à la poste ou six mois j'avais
peur un peu de ses systèmes j'aurais
voulu que ce soit automatisé et tout
mais ça a très bien marché tout film
très bien marché pour cette élection
présidentielle qui a eu lieu au mexique
la plupart des élections vont bien
tourner l'important c'est d'aller voter
sinon c'est ça des roues
son papa s'est plaint sur votre je pense
que notre génération le sait maintenant
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à l'aise
d'être revenue cette semaine rien c'est
toujours merci à mes collègues que la
personne qui dit vous devez venir n'y a
pas de règlement alors c'est on est à la
merci du bon vouloir de tous et chacun
et du de leurs horaires de travail qui
le fermaient ou pas des fois
merci beaucoup à l'est les îles
invitation à la porte est toujours
ouverte
je viendrai tout le temps avec plaisir
qu'on vous envoie un petit ballon pour
les chercheurs sauf que je suis pas
prête à sauter dans les airs par exemple
je ne suis pas assez courageuse
peut-être maryse ma compagne on le fait
20 mai le plus tard chanson on a autant
le goût de le faire alors merci d'avoir
rebondi en studio cette semaine vous
avez piloté comme un champion bravo
merci merci en fait celui qui pilotait
vraiment c'était un chercheur notre ère
c'est un numéro 38 encore cette semaine
pour les adieux d'accord on est prêt oui
à la semaine proche de l'habitation
ouverte comme un champion qui était
vraiment